je suis là pour en tant que partenaires
du projet sur l'eau première qui est un
projet financé par l'union européenne
par les programmes et la seconde place
et c'est un projet qui nous avons
développé avec open it martinique et
martic qui sont des organisations de la
martinique
l'idée du projet est né pour justement
soutenir les gens qui veulent devenir
entrepreneur en travaillant à distance
c'est sale et non solo preneur donc
entrepreneurs en solitaire disons les
projets été développé par wi partners
dont huit organisations différentes qui
représente aussi pays et européennes
donc la france avec la martinique italie
la belgique
sipera et l'islande et l'espagne et donc
on a on a reccueilli des partenaires qui
représentait aussi des régions ultra
périphériques d'europe à l'islande et
les îles canaries canarienne et chypre
avec d'autres partenaires qui sont plus
expert dans la formation sur
l'entrepreneurship sera et sur la
formation à distance et ou bien des
partenaires expert dans les questions
européennes
il ya beaucoup de demande pas ce qui est
mais surtout il faut que les gens
connaissent cette plateforme qui je le
répète en font foi totalement gratuite
est ouvert à tout le monde tous les gens
qui veulent l'utiliser en six langues
les français naturellement mais
l'anglais aussi c'est qu'il nous permet
aussi de par exemple apprendre
la terminologie des business
d'entreprise heures dans la langue
anglaise